[Music]
all right now we didn't talk about this
outfit on the carpet what was the
inspiration behind it what's going on
today well I just want to say one of the
inspirations is to be comfortable Whoopi
Goldberg queen and just have fun
sometimes I take the carpet so seriously
and I get anxious and I start like
freaking out and I can't pose correctly
but this skirt was given to me by Miss
Whoopi Goldberg I said you know what let
me just put on some flat shoes so that
when they have me running around here
doing all the things they need me to do
I can just get up and wink at them and
then my hair you know I'm in love with
all of the fantastic performers that
move Paul's drag race and Bahamas are
right around the corner I'm supposed to
go but I have to go somewhere else I'm
so mad but they've always inspired me to
do fun things with my lucky I brought a
puppy I used to in touch with all the
view girls I do I stay in touch with my
ladies it's it's bittersweet I miss them
I'm happy to be in LA but I miss them
dearly and hopefully you'll see some of
them on the show we'll go like this and
hope but it was fun and I and I enjoyed
being an adult on television which I had
never done before and I really learned a
lot from the ladies on the view
especially will be and all of the
producers behind the scenes I'm still
friends with them so it's good very cool
experience figuring I'm sure you'll get
to go back there with the Ravens home
cast and have a little bit of us
homecoming of a homecoming of a
homecoming they treated us so well for
the the reunion of that's a raven that
hopefully we do get to go back
[Music]
you